hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones Season seven
villains video we're gonna talk about
the biggest baddest best villain so of
course spoilers from everything that's
happened on the show so far so most of
you know that Game of Thrones doesn't
really have straight-up villains it has
a lot of antagonist antagonist is a
better word but you know for the
purposes of this video it's just easier
to call them villains the people that
the subtext is telling you to root
against like everybody always loves
Cersei because Lena Headey is so amazing
but she is most definitely one of the
biggest villains to come out of the end
of season six so you know just right off
the bat I will say she's probably gonna
be my favorite villain of season seven
even though she's written in such a
complex way that you can identify with
why she's doing things but at a certain
point you do have to say like okay she
is definitely the villain of this
Daenerys versus Cersei storyline that's
gonna be happening in the crown lands
because of all the atrocities that she
is committed now Daenerys has killed a
lot of people but she's also freed a lot
of slaves so you know like you kind of
have to balance out the bad things she
does with the good things that she does
and her intentions what is it exactly
that Cersei is fighting for like she
killed a bunch of her own subjects she
wasn't killing enemies of the kingdom
she was killing people that were trying
to kill her like so she was defending
her own life she was being very selfish
and as a consequence of that
Tommen ended up dying Dan and Dave
clarified that the subtext of that whole
event was is that you know the Tommen
was just like going crazy in his head
and probably needed his mother to lead
him through that but then the
realization that his mother was
responsible for this and no one was
there to be with him to help him just
was too much for him so he's just like I
can't handle this I'm out peace
so the counterpoint to that is actually
when Cersei was still you know bad
person but not really an antagonist was
the Blackwater episode where she's
sitting there with Tom and clutching him
thinking that if they lose the battle
Stannis takes the red keep she's going
to commit assisted suicide with her and
Tommen so that they can't be taken alive
so that's a very bad Cersei sympathetic
moment but you know where she's swirling
her wine here and where she walks out on
shamed on like if it wasn't clear when
she blows up the great Sept you know
because everyone was kind of cheering
when that happened because it was so
amazing looking the real Cersei villain
moment of the season was when she
shame none with the mountain knowing
full well what was going to happen oh no
you're not going to die today so it is
totally ok to root for Cersei just
because Lena Headey is so amazing as
long as you remember that she is
probably the bad person in this fight
with Daenerys the actual battle for the
Iron Throne even Jaime is questioning
his loyalty to Cersei now like oh my god
I have no idea what I'm gonna do just
look on his face hair is priceless so
when all the storylines that are gonna
be happening in season 7 just remember
that idea they'll be like fantastic
actors but there will definitely be an
antagonist for each storyline so like up
in the North they've been teasing Jon
Snow vs. anza maybe the you know nothing
part of Jon Snow doesn't realize what's
going on in sonses head how she feels a
little slighted by all the stuff that's
happened in how she might act out as a
result of that in what Littlefinger
might do to take advantage of it so
while Sansa might seem like the
antagonist really Littlefinger is gonna
be the actual villain of that northern
storyline just because he's going to
create as much chaos as possible chaos
is a ladder it all goes back to that
amazing Littlefinger speech but slightly
lesser storylines they'll probably be
some barriers for Sam wealth to cross
like he won't just automatically have
access to everything that he needs at
the Citadel the arch masters have a very
strong opinion about the way they go
about their business and Samwell is
trying to become a maester so he has to
follow their rules and if it wasn't
clear from like the really funny
exchange that he had with that person
when he was entering the Citadel that's
only the beginning he's probably gonna
have a much harder time I'm just I'm not
expecting the season to give us too many
Samwell scenes because there's only
gonna be about seven episodes which
means the story will be less sprawling
which is actually a good thing but bad
and that will have to like cut down on
some other storylines like Samwell at
the Citadel so a lot of you are also
asking what about the White Walkers
won't they be some of the biggest
villains of the season well the funny
thing is the way Dan and Dave talked
about them like they're like well they
represent death in the narrative we
don't think of them as traditional
villains so you can kind of understand
where they're coming from like the White
Walkers are a force of nature like
literally a force of nature our force
created by those who worship nature so
they're kind of more of an ethereal
threat and that's actually the way
they've been using them in this story
don't think they'll be actually like
physical antagonists where you have a
big battle til the final season so while
I still kind of do think of them as
villains I don't think they're gonna be
villains in the sense that Cersei is a
villain of season seven so they'll be
there but they're like the ticking clock
villain like they're just there to
remind you that death is slowly marching
on and it cannot be stopped the really
fun part that I haven't mentioned that
you were probably wondering about is
what about your on I think he's gonna be
the surprise [ __ ] Ramsay villain of
season seven like you thought you forgot
about me but I'm actually a really
terrible person with a pretty large
force at my back so I think in the way
that Ramsay went from being just like an
awful person in a dungeon to being this
really big antagonist I think that Euron
will turn from this person who seems
like a threat into a much bigger threat
in season seven like and if he lines
with anyone it will probably be Cersei
because right now the entire kingdom
hates her even the people in King's
Landing look like they're gonna turn on
her so sir she is gonna seek allies
wherever she can find them in right now
the greatest thing that Euron could do
for Cersei is help make sure that she
still has a steady supply of food coming
into the city because the Tyrells they
basically control most of the food in
the kingdom's because so much of it has
grown on their lands so if she wants to
the queen of thorns could totally starve
Cersei out so she's gonna need to get
food somehow Euron is just one of the
many ways that she could solve that
problem but I know I haven't talked much
about the east there I mean there's
still a lot of big forces in the East
but I think the show has largely come
back to Westeros so most of the
storylines you see will take place in
the Seven Kingdoms like I said one of
the benefits of the story being fewer
episodes as bad as that sounds is that
the story will be less sprawling so I'm
not expecting us to visit the East a
whole lot but let me know in the
comments who's your favorite antagonist
going into season seven like who do you
think is going to be the biggest baddest
best villain right now I still think
that it's going to be Cersei just
because Lena Headey is so fantastic so
they write her that way they write her
to be this amazing villain but I just
love the idea that Daenerys is moving in
with her fort like she has this amazing
large force that she's gonna bring in to
lay siege to King's Landing and it looks
like Cersei zone subjects are gonna turn
on her especially Jaime
even though Lena Headey is price I know
contra
that's gonna take her through season a
so I think they're gonna try and keep
her around as long as possible but that
doesn't necessarily mean that she's
still gonna be sitting on the Iron
Throne in season eight in related
awesome news there is a new round of the
giveaway that starts now is just a $20
Amazon gift card all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video if there are any
Game of Thrones bonus videos that you
guys want this week just let me know in
the comments there's not a whole lot of
news happening right now but I am
expecting a few surprises for wins a
winner in the books and stuff like that
but if you guys didn't know george RR
martin did land another TV series but
it's gonna be at FX it's for his wild
card series that has absolutely nothing
to do with Game of Thrones but there
will be another george RR martin big
epic series that they try to develop for
television so high fives - Martin his
stuff is just blowing up like wildfire
right now while you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for my season 7 teaser trailer breakdown
and you can click here for all my season
7 predictions thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you